these are 50 pence coins are the first  coin with his majesty King Charles face  on on the other side is a special design  to commemorate Queen Elizabeth the  second coronation these are being made  at the Royal Mint you'll still be able  to use the coins you have at the moment  with Queen Elizabeth II's face on that  as they wear out they'll be replaced  with these points  in British history  striking coin for Monarch since the  British family British royal family  began so since ours was a great it's  quite common for male known it's not to  wear a crown on their kindness It's  actually his father his grandfather  because they were on toilet there was no  crowd quite common for female monarchs  away a lot more regalia so prams chiaras  yeah jewelry as well so if that's  probably the comparison people are  making between looking more or less  legal but most people won't see a mail  order for the point in their lifetime